die uefa hat untersagt die münchner
allianz-arena heute abend in
regenbogenfarben zu tauchen
dagmar freitag von der spd ist
vorsitzender des sportausschusses des
deutschen bundestages ich begrüße sie
herzlich in berlin begründung der uefa
ist ja politik und sport zu trennen das
ist doch wohl nachvollziehbar
das hört sich nun nachvollziehbar an
aber entspricht nicht der
lebenswirklichkeit sport ist immer auch
politisch das wissen wir und das weiß
natürlich auch der sport denn der sport
kommt aus der mitte unserer gesellschaft
und da gehören auch
gesellschaftspolitische diskussionen hin
aber die regenbogenfarben heute abend in
münchen eine allianz arena das wäre doch
ein ganz klarer protest gegen ein gesetz
das in ungarn verabschiedet worden ist
ein gesetz das die informationsrechte
von jugendlichen im hinblick auf
homosexualität einschränkt ist es nicht
nachvollziehbar dass man so eine die
politische debatte vom sport abtrennen
will trotzdem ja also für mich ist das
nicht nachvollziehbar denn ich finde es
hochproblematisch jungen heranwachsenden
in einer ganz sensiblen phase ihres
lebens den zugang zu notwendigen
informationen zu verwehren und ich würde
es anders formulieren ich würde nicht
sagen das ist ein signal gegen etwas ich
würde sagen die regenbogen sind farben
sind ein signal für etwas nämlich für
toleranz für toleranz in hinblick auf
unterschiedliche lebensformen die es in
den gesellschaften übrigens weltweit
gibt und nicht nur in deutschland und
somit eben auch in ungarn und es ist
einfach ein zeichen pro
mitmenschlichkeit und nicht gegen
irgendetwas nun wirklich an diesen tagen
die uefa massiv kritisiert auch gerade
für diese entscheidung die münchen
betrifft auf der anderen seite hat ja
die uefa in den letzten jahren schon
einiges getan um sozusagen auch rechte
von minderheiten beispielsweise zu
schützen würde ich denke jetzt nur mal
an die initiative respekt oder auch
games ist das nicht genug
ja das ist genau die frage
man kann natürlich initiativen starten
man kann respekt auf die banden im
stadion schreiben aber wenn es gilt
diese worte mit leben zu füllen dann
versagen internationale sportverbände
regelmäßig und das ist eben das problem
dass worte letztlich doch nicht mit
taten einhergehen wo sind sie denn für
sie die grenzen wie weit darf man denn
beim fußball auch politische meinung
äußern
die vermischung von fußball politik ist
ja längst tagtäglich vorhanden zb
gazprom ist ja einer der sponsoren der
uefa wir werden im nächsten jahr auch
höchst umstrittenen katar die fußball
weltmeisterschaft austragen soll auch
dort jeweils immer protest gezeigt
werden naja die diskussionen laufen ja
als sie wissen wir haben lange jahre
über die arbeitsverhältnisse in katar
beispielsweise diskutiert und das gehört
eben dazu und sie haben ja selber den
widerspruch gerade aufgezeigt die
sportverbände haben überhaupt kein
problem mit solchen staaten mit
autokratischen staaten oder auch mit
deren sponsoren hoch lukrative
werbeverträge abzuschließen
aber wenn es mal darum geht im wahrsten
sinne des wortes flagge zu zeigen dann
wird es relativ dürftig und ich finde
das ist schon etwas was wir deutlich
machen müssen und persönlich glaube ich
dass die uefa ein wirkliches eigentor
geschossen hat es wird möglicherweise
viel mehr über das was jetzt passiert
ist diskutiert die washington post
beispielsweise greift das thema
regenbogenfarben in münchen heute auf
ich glaube die uefa hat nicht erkannt
welche weltweite welle sind damit
auslöst und beifall gab es ja eigentlich
auch nur aus um garten frage ist doch
aber heute abend und es wird ja
sicherlich auch die kundgebung im
stadion geben sollen ja regenbogenfarben
verteilt werden vor dem stadion sind
nicht leidtragenden am ende die spieler
die nämlich dann heute abend die
ungarischen spieler die heute abend dort
spielen müssen die möglicherweise selbst
gar nicht mit dem gesetz in ihrer heim
einverstanden sind ist denn dass nicht
diejenigen die nachher darunter leiden
es ist glaube ich eher nicht dass ich
habe zumindest auch von einem spieler
der ungarischen mannschaft lesen der
sich sehr deutlich
pro rein lokales positioniert hat und
ich glaube mündige bürger und
bürgerinnen und das sind natürlich auch
fußballspieler können mit
gesellschaftspolitischen diskussionen
umgehen wenn deutschland heute abend
bund wird wenn das stadion in münchen
heute abend bund wird ist das einfach
ein ausdruck einer freien gesellschaft
und ich finde das ist ein gutes zeichen
eine frage habe ich noch nie hat auch
irgendwas mit sport politik zu tun aber
ist ein anderes thema ist nämlich corona
und sport
die austragung von em-spielen in
großbritannien
da sind sie ja nicht gerade ein fan von
aber die uefa sagt sie sieht momentan
keine möglichkeit und auch keinen grund
diese spiele zu verlegen sind sie damit
einverstanden reicht ihnen das als
antwort nein das ist keine antwort es
gibt alternativen ministerpräsident
söder hat ganz klar erklärt dass münchen
beispielsweise als alternativstandort
zur verfügung stehen würde
und wenn ich sehe wie in welchem ausmaß
die delta variante im moment in
großbritannien kassiert halte ich eine
entscheidung ein stadion mit 60.000
zuschauern zu füllen
für schlichtweg unverantwortlich das
sagt dagmar freitag von der spd
vorsitzender des sportausschusses im
deutschen bundestag herzlichen dank für
das interview